foreign
school I am hella Mark Harley and you
know what we have an interesting one
today I am gonna jump right in to
calling up the founder of oakenstone
clothing
um he's a guy who obviously have a
business relationship promoting the the
clothes that I'm wearing right now on
the show but you know we've been talking
last few weeks and he dropped like he's
in uh Sarasota Florida so
the reason I wanted to call him up is As
I got more details about what he'd
experienced during this hurricane I
think it was an important lesson for me
that sometimes
it's good to tune out news and you know
not have that negativity affect your
brain but sometimes
you can do that
to a point where you forget that there
are individuals experiencing extreme
hardships and
for me
um you know I just until he told me the
details of some of the things that he
was going through in the business was
going through and the people in general
that he's not even portraying himself as
a victim he's going to look a lot of
people out a lot worse but I thought it
was going to be a good idea to check in
with him
and just let him tell you a little bit
about that in your early words because I
want to
you know use the platforms that we have
here thick boy and on my Instagram and
uh and whatnot to see if we can just
give back a little bit or do something
for a guy who has been an amazing person
to me an amazing family man running a
business having a full-time job outside
of that and also who's now currently
volunteering a lot of his time to
um
you know the relief effort in his
community and outside so let's see if we
can get him on the phone right now
Hey Brother how's it going hey it's good
it's going good
um I was just giving a little bit of an
intro into the situation here and just
basically saying that
you know it's easy to tune out negative
news and sometimes I don't think that's
a terrible idea especially when it comes
to like National politics but um you
know when it comes to disasters and and
these uh
occurrences I decided it was really
insightful talking to you and to wrap my
mind around like the specifics of what
you're going through
um in order you know to to mobilize
people to help so with that being said
what has this hurricane been like for
you what is the aftermath of the
hurricane been like and and maybe you
could also tell like what was it like
during it because you mentioned a little
bit about that in our last conversation
yeah well I mean you know it's about me
Mark I'm a Florida boy uh so I've
definitely been through my fair share of
hurricanes but uh this one was unique in
the sense that it was a slow moving
storm uh it was very large and it
brought a lot of water and a lot of wind
so the storm itself and kind of took
about 12 hours uh to pass through
um normally they're a lot quicker than
that
um and it affected it's such a large
area and uh where where we're located
where ons is located we were actually
really blessed we did we didn't get the
worst of the storm
um but about 30 45 minutes south of us I
mean it's just it was just complete
Devastation
um and um you know it's just the the
storm itself you know you you kind of
just sitting there waiting for it to be
over you look you lose power and you're
just you hear the noise you don't really
have cell service and you you're just
kind of sitting there wondering like
what the hell was going on like when is
this going to be over
but the beauty is uh even through all
the devastation and and the turmoil
um it's been uh
amazing to see the best of humanity come
out
um and what I mean by that is you know
the next day I mean like right after the
storm hit uh you just saw this Caravan
of people coming down with trucks and
trailers and supplies and not just like
government officials but everyday
citizens coming from Texas from up North
you know these guys just came and
they're just like we're just here to
help
um you know the the deficitation I can't
understand the devastation I mean
I mean we're seeing a lot of people
have lost their lives have lost their
homes
um because we weren't as affected in
Sarasota uh uh as bad as uh our our
Southern
um communities
um you know they're busting people up
here and
um to stay in shelters because they've
literally lost everything yeah and you
said you saw kids like on the street who
yeah you need to be reconnected with
their parents or don't know where the
parents are yeah
part is just you know you see these
misplaced kids and they're getting
picked up by FEMA
um you know trying to connect them back
with their parents and you know you just
you don't know the whole story so you're
just sitting there what like hoping like
I hope their parents are still alive
yeah um you know and unfortunately
you're seeing you know people getting
you know dead bodies being pulled out of
rivers and and
um and canals and it's just a it's a
it's a bad situation
um but you know we're the community is
just really rallied together and just
they and it feels like it feels like
almost the exact opposite of the
pandemic I think I told you that yeah
yeah when we talked earlier I thought
that was an interesting observation yeah
the pandemic you know
even though we had the tagline We're All
in This Together it didn't feel like it
right you know you were scared of every
person that you interact with interacted
with and you know this is what you know
we we hoped for in any sort of trauma
and any sort of tragedies people coming
together if you have things that you
need and you're you're safe and you're
and you're good you know the people that
are in that position they're doing
everything they can to help you know
whether it be just helping their
neighbor uh clean up debris
um help repairing you know holes in
their roof you know a buddy of mine he
um a tree just fell through his roof uh
and there's just a mask hole in the
ceiling so people seeing people come
together and and help them tarp it and
help them clean up you know it's
um like I said in the worst of tragedy
man the best of humanity can come out
and it's it's a really beautiful thing
yeah but the biggest means honestly
um has been just um
like obviously fuel has been an issue
but they seem to be getting as much fuel
as they can because people are obviously
running generators uh to power uh our
our offices
um just received power a couple days ago
think you know that which was good you
know I was uh that was hindering us from
really doing anything and thankfully we
didn't have any damage to our building
or inventory or or and everybody at home
base is safe
um but the biggest needs honestly is
just helping with rebuilding
um there there is a fund I believe is a
Florida Recovery Fund
um that is that is helping
um people just get back on their feet
get in the Necessities that they need
just I mean I mean just imagine the
things that you would need if you
completely lost everything you know so
they're they're they're needing clothing
they're needing uh toothpaste
toothbrushes so all these there's a lot
of organizations that have come together
to to help get provide the essentials to
people that have lost everything yeah
okay so that's the Florida recount every
fund I think we could probably end on
that call to action and
um you know I was just going to say as
you as you said you see the best in
humanity come out and uh and hopefully
that translates to other people watching
this if you have any money or anything
you can spare even if it's to spare
clothing you know I'm sure they'd
appreciate that as well and I'm sure
there's lots of instructions on that
site but um you know I my heart goes out
to you I'm sure everybody listening or
watching this uh their hearts go out to
you as well and I just wanted to
initiate this conversation while we
could even though I feel like you know
we're going to keep talking about it and
and keep giving people more specific
reminders of how they can help and just
you know I hope you go support that and
um you know and also support oakenstone
as a member of you know a business in
that Community
um you know because you're you're a part
of the community that's been affected so
um with that Ricardo I think we'll be
talking uh soon probably over the
weekend and uh and we'll keep reminding
people what to do
Mark I really appreciate you and
everybody at thinkboy I mean you guys
have been amazing through this whole
process checking in and and just working
with us so I I really appreciate you
guys yeah we appreciate you a lot too
and uh we'll talk soon okay all right
talk soon bye-bye
all right
you know uh I realize some of you may
have some some listeners and viewers may
have tuned out already but it was
important to me to get that message up
because again
tragedies like this sometimes you know
you can't always take on that level of
empathy to think about all the people
suffering in the world at once but you
know it does if you're part of this
community and you watch a show and you
know my connection to Oak and stone
um
that was important to me it humanizes it
enough where I go yes I really feel like
I have to do something I should do
something that's what's right and I'm
asking you if you're able to to join me
in attempting to Aid in any way possible
to that recovery effort now
moving on to something much lighter
hella confusing ass injuries and a new
segment here if I told you guys
um about this bicep injury that I've had
I forget of how much I've talked about
it but it's like because of my shoulder
issues
um
there was this like like a few months
ago six months seven months eight months
I don't know when I was in Arizona
working out with Chappelle that's my
memory of it what happened was I'm doing
like a heavy row and I see like part of
the muscle seemingly is like popping out
of my bicep like a little you know a
bump or like a little like alien kind of
thing going Boop when I'm Contracting it
looked very odd but also it's not
painful so you're going
what is going on here because I have no
idea right normally an injury like that
should cause extreme pain but it didn't
and the first thing that came to my mind
was oh this must be a fascia tear right
and the fascist the lining of your
muscle
it sort of keeps your muscle in place
and in shape you know and part of for
example DC training and the extreme
stretching protocol that's a part of it
is to stretch the fascia lining and deep
tissue massage in theory
um could potentially loosen that up
because that's you know the primary
impediment like as a bodybuilder
um to getting the most massive muscles
that you can is simply this hard lining
of your muscle that's a very
um strong fibrous lining that keeps
everything in shape so I don't know if
you can see this right maybe I should
take my
my arm out you guys can
is that can you see it can you see the
monitor right so when I go like that
there we go right so it's like that's at
rest like this should hurt right and
it's kind of revealed itself to be this
because at first it was just swelling
and uh you couldn't really tell what was
going on my whole arm filled up with
fluid and this had happened a number of
times but it's kind of settled on this
this thing
that's left there that it's essentially
like a hernia within my muscle it's like
a muscle shooting through this hole in
the lining of my fascia so I've been
corresponding with my buddy Dr Austin
chase in Canada who I'm going to see for
the first time in a few weeks uh we've
been mainly online buddies but he helped
me out with my shoulder issues ETC and
uh and he's saying you know he could
potentially like move it back into place
I don't know if that's possible he
hasn't gone quite into detail about that
but it was like you know he used some
medical term that I wasn't familiar with
as but I knew he meant to like realign
it or put it back into place and
otherwise I guess it would be a surgery
now
the reason I bring this up because who
gives a [ __ ] it's not even painful it's
whatever it's essentially a minor
inconvenience it made me think about how
back when I was in college I had a buddy
who got a
um
an injury to his clavicle and uh
specifically like where it you know your
clavicle bone connects to your shoulder
up here so like it almost like detached
and it stuck out a little bit
and I remember thinking how he didn't
seem bothered by it but like if I had
that injury it would bother me a lot
because it like it looks sort of
grotesque you know it's like this part
if you follow your clavicle all the way
up here it's like imagine where that
inserts and then like raise that by two
inches it sort of makes other people
uncomfortable looking at it as I'm sure
my bicep makes other people look
uncomfortable looking at it as it is now
um
it makes me think about how
like we deal with it's like a little
adversity right it's a little something
that you're dealing with and you go this
is an ideal but it also doesn't Define
me and that's an analogy for anything
you don't like about yourself right
people don't like their nose they don't
like their hair they don't like their
teeth they don't like their body
um
and I think
you have one of two options you can
either focus on it and it's easy to
focus on and I'm not saying I haven't
mastered like I'm still touching this
all the time and kind of trying to push
it back in and stuff like that but life
goes on right and I think I'm just
grateful that I'm in a position to be
like Matt life goes on I'm not a
competitive bodybuilder where this is
going to ruin my you know stage
aesthetic or something like that
ultimately it's a reminder to me that
yeah these little things happen and it's
a knock to your vanity or your sense of
symmetry but anything like this
um
you know that's essentially you might
look at somebody else and go like oh man
that would suck to have that but then
when it's on you
um you know any SCAR or a symmetry or
thing that you don't like
do more stuff that makes you think about
other things and the busier you are and
uh you know for me it's like even just
exercising not having time to sit around
and feel sorry for yourself even
something as stupid as this because
obviously yes people are suffering from
hurricane damage in the world and that's
why I wanted to contrast it with that
segment
um because
it's something that
I can compartmentalize and put away and
know that I'll deal with it at some
point but I'm almost like I'm surprised
at you know how I'm kind of going around
and I'm I have a lack of
self-consciousness about it I guess
maybe at another time
I wouldn't have I'd look at it and go oh
my God I need to chop my entire arm off
right now
soon I may have to do that but just not
right now a lot of people have been
asking me
Mark somebody did actually ask you today
they said yo what are the strains of
Kratom that you use
um like do a deep dive on this honestly
I don't think about the strains that I
use that much what I have here is the
Kratom energy shot that I use it just
says full spectrum extract I don't know
I like the taste I like the serving one
time I took two of these in a row I'm
like oh one feels good two be great I
wasn't ready
you know but you have to experiment with
stuff like that to know like that was a
little too much for me I am somebody who
believes in the minimum effective dose
and
uh in this case
one works for me you know if you build
up a tolerance over time you know if you
want more do one and a half due to but
it's kind of like nicotine Casey you
smoke at all you use any sort of
nicotine yeah okay so you know that look
yeah one cigarette might be good two in
a row or whatever you know if you're
sensitive to it it can make you ill so
am I saying this gonna make you ill no
but I'm saying this is the perfect dose
I'm a large man and this is great for me
oh that was great audio
go go go go go go go go and it tastes
good and so that's this is what I use
since you guys are all curious about it
happy hippoherbals.com
use promo code thick boy with three C's
at checkout for 20 off thank you as you
guys heard from Ricardo with oakenstone
the whole Community down there is going
through a difficult time he now has
access to his uh warehouse and
everything's fine luckily the inventory
wasn't damaged but you know that's I
would consider it one of the ways you
can contribute to this
community and this individual again who
I think is a great guy he's a great
family man and he's really trying to do
good in this world and uses time energy
and resources to help rebuild the
community so support him by going to
oakenstoneclothing.com using promo code
hello for 10 off check out get something
like this and you'll be looking fly and
also kind of like helping do good in the
world so juntos
megusta okay let's get into some hella
Fitness drama I thought it was funny
that uh
Caleb Vaughn moger did I say it right I
think I did he's in trial in Australia
right now for this road rage incident
where I guess he got out of the car and
like chased somebody down with a machete
and his lawyer's defense I thought was
really funny
um on his behalf he was saying that due
to
trauma that he endured while living in
Los Angeles because of the crime and
carjackings in Los Angeles and I don't
think he had even experienced one on his
own but he's using that his experience
in Los Angeles and the crime ridden
streets of whatever nice neighborhood he
was staying in uh that had caused him to
go berserk in Australia against some
stranger on the street who cut him off
or whatever
I guess this is normal that people
construct these elaborate you know BS
like oh I've gone crazy uh temporary
insanity whatever
but it was just hilarious to me that
he's using like actually you know my
experience in Los Angeles and and the
notion that carjackings existed uh as as
your defense for almost murdering
somebody in the streets of Sydney
Australia cool and also they always
bring up this like he takes testosterone
also because his body doesn't naturally
produce at the owls have to get out of
the rabbit hole of like well the only
reason that he takes testosterone it's
like obviously he takes more than trt uh
the guy is Jews to the gills and I'm not
mad at it he looks great his competitive
bodybuilder he played Arnold in
um that Joe Weider documentary and
crushed it but like he's not just on
testosterone because his body doesn't
naturally produce it he made the
decision to take all sorts of steroids
and then also mix that with recreational
substances
such as meth and cocaine and as you
might be able to predict
the outcome of mixing meth Coke and
anabolic steroids isn't good it's not
going to lead to you being more calm if
you have any mental issues to begin with
especially so
I feel like this always just grinds my
you know what really grinds my gears it
grabs my gears because it's putting out
this notion right that a trt dose of
testosterone that you can get prescribed
by your doctor is going to make you
freak the [ __ ] out on people in the
middle of the street that's just not
true and there's so many millions of
people in the world right now taking
either trt or a generous trt Sports trt
which I consider like 250 milligrams or
more
or straight up anabolic steroids who
never act out of line who never have
anger issues who never beat anybody up
or hop out of a car and Chase somebody
down with a machete so this notion
that there's even you know a correlation
let alone causation that's still in the
minority and you know many people do
crazy things like this every day without
those hormones so I just think it's up
to you as an individual to take
responsibility and
not make the choice to do that and work
on your own emotional maturity because
anytime I look at somebody and I think
Jordan Peterson made this point of like
you know think of a baby throwing a
tantrum or not even a baby like a
toddler right where you can actually
throw yourself on the ground and have a
fit and get really angry and be
emotional to the point of being out of
control
now imagine an adult doing that and what
you have
is somebody like Calum freaking out not
a stranger with a machete right it's
very scary but I still see that as the
result of a lack of emotional maturity a
lack of willingness to work on yourself
and clearly the guy's taking zero
responsibility in his court defense I
mean maybe I don't know if it's
beneficial to come out and just say like
yeah I did it like I went down a dark
path and I was on drugs and like I'm the
answer to that is I'm working on rehab
so you should reduce my sentence instead
he's taking this approach of like was it
my fault like I was crazy and uh you
know carjacker is in Los Angeles that I
may have never even run into are the
cause of this erratic dangerous Behavior
so the lesson to me there is just like
dude own your [ __ ] stop chasing people
down with a machete in the middle of the
whatever the Sydney freeway is
do you know what it is
I can look it up you know you know what
it's called you know the major freeway
in Sydney scope the for the the flow row
five I was going down the 101 in the
405.
and he said I just want to go home
that's what the other guy said I just
want to go home
and he's chasing me down with a bloody
machete okay
liver King recap here I just wanted to
touch base because yes yes the liver
King was on my show for a absolutely
full sit-down interview
do I feel bad about clickbaiting you no
because I was so excited about just the
fact that he
um came in and gave us that
uh that minute of his time you know
because this is a guy
you know I'll start
from the beginning if you're watching
that episode I shot the first part and
then we went into the second part where
the liver King like I didn't know if the
liver King was going to be giving us his
time or not so I had to shoot the
episode like hopefully that episode
started out with him doing something
with me but I don't know either way it's
cool but like you know you were talking
to
uh Mark who didn't know the future that
was being presented as the past and it
was like this whole crazy timeline thing
going on uh like Interstellar it was
just absolutely it was a Christopher
Nolan movie yeah I was going to say that
episode was directed by Christopher that
was directed by Augusta for now
let's change the credits
um because we can do it now and then act
like it was always there because in The
Fifth Dimension you see that
um
what's that do you believe in time
travel I do what yes do you I don't know
man I've been thinking a lot about it
lately okay this episode took a hard
departure but I'm gonna we're gonna go
there let's go there okay so you say you
do yes well tell us about it okay
um essentially ever since I read the
book The Elegant Universe by John Green
yes I'm a genius Let It Go no this is
this was sent to me by a friend of mine
who was a physics major and she knew
that I had like physics in high school
honors physics was probably my favorite
class right
um I was a selectively good student but
physics was quite just love the
problem-solving element and like I was
like you know I just should have I
always felt like I should have done more
with it now of course as you get to
upper level physics in college like the
math and the straight it's like unless
you're doing something in the sciences
and these are two people who like
they did hardcore math and so I'm
thinking of a guy and a girl who got
married but the girl Izzy Smith like
went on to be an academic physicist
right so she sent me this book and it
was one of these things that I used to
like you know read during cardio and I
remember it was like the last book that
I'm like this like blew my mind you know
Malcolm Gladwell books are cool but like
read the elegant universe and he
basically breaks down
well he starts off by setting you up
to understand String Theory because if
you don't understand the principles of
general relativity as outlined by
Einstein you know as a revolution from
Isaac Newton's way of thinking which I
guess you know and I don't even like I'm
not saying I'm going to articulate this
perfectly but like
to me when I think of Newton it's like
he came up with the principles of like
this is how gravity affects you on earth
right but you need to understand like
the space time continuum for example in
order to see how Mass warps the the time
space continuum right and so gravity is
a static thing like you know you know
when you're however [ __ ] far away
from the Earth's core which doesn't
really you know we're not getting these
huge differences but then you go out in
space whatever so Einstein expanded upon
that but then
um and it kind of like goes to these
he's like I'd say this this is what
happens when you go to these great
distances and these huge masses and all
this stuff but like what about on the
tiniest tiniest tiniest tiniest tiniest
you know
um distances a plank length under a
plank length is what they call it things
start to behaviorally weird and that's
where you get into this like because
there's no explanation of quantum
mechanics right do you know about
quantum mechanics or not no I know well
I like like but also this is one of
these things where people go like
anybody's saying they know a lot about
quantum mechanics like you know even if
you're an academic but it's basically
the bizarre things that start to happen
when you get under a certain subatomic
uh you know size things behave very much
like a Christopher Nolan movie The
analogies that he would use is like
imagine flying to Hawaii on a plane and
you you fuel up for that trip upon
arrival you know what I mean like
please include okay space because when
Casey hits you with one of these you
know you got a z a doozy on your hand
right
um but it's almost you know like it's
it's sort of analogy to like time travel
or it's like it's like energy travel you
know what I mean it's like do you think
you could travel back in time
yeah and that's all leading to in this
book he broke down the notion of how
space and time can be distorted or like
you know they use this printable
actually in interstellar because they go
like when they're close to the black
hole gravity warps time right and also
speed warps time so right now we are
traveling through time at the fastest
rate possible it's like we're traveling
through time at the speed of light if we
travel to and that's a vector right so
like imagine you're like watching a car
go in this Vector at 100 miles an hour
if it came straight at the camera or
straight this way you can't like measure
the the speed as much it just looks like
it's coming at you or away from you
right it's almost you can see it's
slightly getting bigger but like
the fourth dimension of time is just
another Vector if we're standing still
in one vector we're traveling through
time maximally if we travel through this
Vector because right right now we're
going zero if you approach the speed of
light then time slows down but if you
approach a black hole that's like the
densest thing in the universe time every
second you know it time slows down
completely and but your experience of it
like somebody else would be like oh
that's a year and you're just like no
that was a second so that kind of [ __ ]
I'm like oh my God this is like
verifiable you know what I mean and you
could even do small scale experiments if
you were out like just further away from
Earth you know if you spent a year up
there and you had a clock on you'd be
like oh our clocks don't quite match up
because of the discrepancy in gravity
because of that I go oh you can
essentially time travel going one way
right
like you could essentially like you
could freeze you could you could travel
to the Future by traveling at the speed
of light or Beyond I don't know if it's
possible whatever but like it showed me
how you would just be the same age going
at the speed of light you get back and
be like oh I've traveled 70 years in the
future without aging myself
and
I think everything else is like there
it's like you know you go to [ __ ] in
a plane like that's almost a form of
time travel you know because we're just
like we used to measure it and oh it
took you like you know 30 days to get
from here to here and you'd age 30 days
well I can travel 30 days without aging
30 days and I because of that I'm like
imagine
you know a hundred thousand years in the
future
we haven't developed technology that
could warp that in the opposite
direction
until proven otherwise I would assume
like the most advanced technology that
Humanity could ever achieve is capable
final answer
now what do you think AC I I I agree
no man I've been watching a lot of
YouTube videos about it I don't
understand any of it it makes me feel
dumb but like um homeboy who's homeboy
Neil deGrasse Tyson yep yep the only
person that anybody knows with regards
but why not you know at least it's
somebody right because that could be
nobody you could name the physicist and
people like you know yeah I've been
watching him try uh try and kind of
explain it um
the Paradigm of like you can't go back
in time and uh like prevent your parents
from meeting thus preventing you from
existing because then you wouldn't exist
to go back and do it right and so those
are like philosophical questions almost
to me the the and I I answered it like
technologically could we could we like
Bend space-time I think that I'm unclear
like so when people like you know is it
like Back to the Future I don't [ __ ]
know right but like that's debatable and
he was what was he saying about that
what was he saying about that oh he was
like basically kind of echoing what
you're saying like yeah
the math checks out that it's yeah
possible yeah the application of it
doesn't exist yeah kind of basically
that's the very dumb yeah but yeah
that's my interpretation because again I
don't have to look I'm sure I could read
the elegant Universe a number of it's
actually it's written if you guys want
to check this out you know
um it's written for not for not a
physicist and that's why this girl sent
it to me she's like hey you're sort of a
hobbyist in this one particular field
it's written so that if you have any
sort of you know if you took High School
physics or not
um I think it would still be accessible
it's just like a lot of reading to get
to the point where they're like and look
how crazy string theory is and string
theory may or may not be right but it's
like one possible explanation of like
the principles of quantum mechanics
which are very confusing and but if you
extend even the notion of quantum
mechanic like quantum mechanics is time
travel because it's like like you get
energy after arriving someplace for you
know what I mean like that bends the
principle of time because it bends the
principle of causation one thing that I
remember thinking about after reading
this book was like The Big Bang Theory
there need not be a people go here's the
the religious argument what came before
the Big Bang or even a philosophical
argument really
there is no before the Big Bang because
if time sort of slows down you know in a
black hole imagine right it's the
densest thing in the universe
the Big Bang would emerge from
essentially everything in the universe
being a black hole you know
because time and space are intertwined
there is no before it's just nothing
there is no time either so we're not
measuring beforehand so it's like time
emerges with the explosion of that big
bang the universe is expanding still
will there come a point where it starts
to retract could we be in an infinite
series of expansions and attractions
right but it just sort of follows
mathematically that you're like no
there's you you can't think of things
before and after or even in any sort of
standard unit of time Across the
Universe it's really to this day
probably the most interesting book I've
ever read like and I was saying I could
probably read it 10 times in a row and
still find like new things that kind of
like
because some of the stuff you're reading
you're like I can't even stop to like
think about that right now you know but
just there's also just some basic
principles of like
if you're passing somebody trained you
can't tell what what velocity they're at
you know and this is another Neil
deGrasse Tyson thing where he's like you
feel acceleration people go I have a
Need for Speed somebody's saying this he
goes you have a need for acceleration
because you can't feel speed which we're
we're going really fast right now
through the universe right and you know
how the universe Travels by the way we
think of like I'm spinning around the
solar system it's like this
because like we're part of this whole
thing like the sun is traveling also the
sun is orbiting something else so
depending on your fixed point of view
yes we're nerding about out about
physics today it's okay
um
I might even might even read that book
again because it's just so good and
there's always something I don't know
like but and that's really cool too like
we can go on YouTube and be like that's
your entree into this I don't always
need like an entire book like blow my
mind in five minutes you'll deGrasse
Tyson
can do that and um why not why not have
him be a physics Superstar okay
I was gonna do another book maybe I'll
get back to it I've been officer reading
Blitz which is about like
methamphetamine use and the the World
War II which I thought was fascinating
because we all kind of know like yes the
German soldiers used meth right but it's
actually way more interesting than that
to see how like it had permeated the
culture prior to that you know and they
were selling it like Pez to the entire
Community
um but I wanted to go into Sub full my
workout with Angelina Maldonado
so this girl she's uh
she's somebody who if you follow Brad or
Zoo culture or anybody she's
um you know a fitness influencer now I
just want to give her credit because
we've been talking like I'll see her
around she's friends with Isaiah and
Noel so like you know I've just seen her
around we all got our nails done one
time I got pedicures and I thought that
was funny and a couple things impress
upon me and that we talked about today
like because she'll go oh yeah people
kind of like tell me they assume I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] or whatever and I guess
that's true I I've known her for a
little bit now I've known that she's a
very nice person but like
one of these girls said maybe you look
at her face and just think that she's
you know the resting [ __ ] face right
um
it's hard to kind of see now maybe but
like you know she gets that a lot but
I've experienced her as nothing but
really sweet and thoughtful in person
we've been kind of like you know you
like you say like oh work out with you
some time we'll work out with you
sometime
um
but I was at zoo culture this morning
and we'd been talking oh yeah let's go
like work out and do some time like not
even it's always like loose like you
know what are we gonna do hit just
whatever I was waiting for Brendan he
was busy doing some stuff like sometimes
we'll say like Okay meet up at nine and
then because you're putting out fires
with your multiple businesses or
whatever or situations like you know
that ends up getting pushed back so I
noticed Angelina was there and she was
about to do a workout I said what are
you doing she's like I'm gonna do the
circuit of uh you know we started off
doing so she was gonna start off doing
squats then box jumps then
um leg raises so she was like basically
full body circuit I'm like I'm down with
that that's a workout style that I've
used before it's a great benefit I
really like working out like that I
think it's a great way to fit in cardio
and get some hypertrophy training in
there maybe not maximize your
hypertrophy training but like you're
gonna be exhausted
and so during the course of that workout
I saw something that I think separates
her from both men and women that I often
work out with
she Embraces intensity
we did four rounds of 15 rep squats so I
was using 225 I think she went from like
95 to like you know 115 to 135
um which you know for
it's probably around her weight
um you know it was relatively intense
and 15 reps of anything on Squad is
intense then I think she was doing 10 to
15 box jumps at a pretty you know on a
pretty high platform
like at least uh you know waist high and
then like 10 to 15 reps of the hanging
knee raises which she has impeccable
form on
four rounds of that and then Brandon
showed up but she was so we did our
deadlift workout but she was still gonna
go with like using the same weight for
lunges and uh kettlebell like Romanian
deadlifts into pull-ups like four more
rounds of that and I was like God damn
you don't see a lot of people working
out like that outside of a CrossFit
context and I go okay so where'd you
pick this up
like what what program do you follow and
she's like I've always done my
programming myself and I'm like there we
go
that's dope because that's how I feel
like I don't really like following other
people's programs I get inspired by them
but ultimately it's like one of the only
things in my life where I can have
complete control over so even working
out with other people
I kind of like to as always say I think
you need to learn how to work out with
yourself first don't always be reliant
on a gym partner
and also don't be a reliant on a workout
program figure out what you like and
what works for you and experiment with
your own intensity because sometimes
people get caught in this thing of like
oh three sets of ten or five sets of
five and it's like or go in and do 20
sets of bench press
see how you like it that could be your
entire chest workout there's nothing
wrong with that and sometimes when
you're negotiating with somebody else
it's always like it can be a hindrance
like what do you want to do well go in
and experience it's hard to experiment
when you have to negotiate with somebody
because you can't just go on your whim
and be like today I'm only gonna do you
know a bunch of heavy squats or do a
circuit style training and that's kind
of how I developed it and also you know
how I initially met Chappelle was he
would come work out with me and he would
allow me to do stuff like that and he
wouldn't be like no I don't feel like
doing that because the moment somebody
does that it's like oh my God [ __ ] off
um but Chappelle was really great about
you know just listening to my ideas for
like all right we've got this circuit
we're gonna do like the landmine we're
gonna do presses into rows into rdls
into lunges into like whatever the [ __ ]
this AB thing is
um and he'd be down right and so I'm
like okay we can work out because you're
not interfering with my experimentation
process
I was impressed with Angelina because
she has an amazing physique she has
really well developed legs she has a
really well developed upper body and
she's very lean
you don't see physiques like this a lot
I think anywhere you don't see it at zoo
and there's like some really you know
girls in great shape and Sue right
and maybe you're just born like that and
you know maybe you have like really
prominent ABS or whatever like you know
when I look at her body you assume she
works hard but maybe not you know maybe
you don't work out that hard but you
kind of have good genetics and just
don't eat anything but like
this girl I think has a physique that a
lot of women would
want to emulate and she has a lot of
muscle on her upper body
how she gets that I discovered today is
she works her ass off she puts herself
by coming up with these workout ideas
through her own extremely difficult
workouts and I have nothing but
admiration for that and I also found out
today that she played High School
football she was a kicker and she kind
of glossed over and I'm like so what's
your athletic background like did you do
you know swimming or gymnastics or you
know like because usually people who are
in their early 20s who are very muscular
have some sort of athletic background
just like I did some track and then I
played football and then I'm like wait
wait wait she's glossing over it like oh
yeah no big deal uh but she she was the
kicker but she's still like she
participated in like eight on eight in
the off season and stuff and you know
she was lifting with the boys since she
was like 14 years old and I'm like that
makes sense checks out and I just think
that's dope and I want to give people
attention like that because you're gonna
look at her page and focus on her looks
rightfully so but just know that in
person this girl works her ass off and
it's no mistake that she looks the way
she does and so I asked her to come on
the podcast sometimes she's like oh my
God who me like I'm not even that
interesting I'm like yes you are
yes Queen
um hopefully we get her on because I do
think she has an interesting story and
an interesting perspective even from uh
you know for the fact that she's 23.
what else do we got next this is why we
can't have nightstands sure why not
I think I was talking about the liver
King before it got totally distracted
we're going to come back to it though
I'm gonna take a nice little segue into
uh this guy's looking he's like pulling
you know she's doing the thing where the
girls you know like they girls love
pulling things between their legs
whether that's you know for the the
shoulder raises like this or oh he's
trying to smell it yeah I bet you see
this I see what he's doing he's smelling
your vajayjay I think is what's going on
guys
and I'm all about that dude it's like if
you're gonna go to a public gym and rub
that cable on your vagina well guys
you're gonna try to smell it aren't they
like this one dude look how quickly this
escalates this girl comes in here but
like the shoulder bump sucker like she
might as well tackle her out of the way
and the speed with which they jump to
like a Greco-Roman hair pulling contest
is quite incredible did I just make that
phrase up Greco-Roman hair pulling
contest yes what I mean is they're
locking their upper bodies up like a
Greco-Roman style wrestling match except
they're also pulling on each other's
hair and I just love to see this kind of
territorial competition between women in
a gym environment it tells me that
they're devoted they're into it like no
you're not going to take my [ __ ]
Smith machine dude I'm trying to get my
fat ass in shape yes I look like a
refrigerator right now but six months
from now maybe not so much okay I'm
trying to change that SpongeBob physique
for something that looks more like
Angelina Maldonado okay now when we got
here
me dealing with any minor can
inconvenience after missing the gym that
day you know and I watched this on a day
where like I hadn't worked out yet I'm
like I relate to this dude Everything's
Gonna Make Me Snap and I swear to God
this is to this day one of the reasons
that I go to the gym because I know I'm
just more prone
to treating people poorly or making rash
decisions out of anger or frustration
um than I would be if I went to the gym
that day it sets the tone I'll repeat
this always but like when people tell me
oh I have anger issues like yeah go run
10 miles go do a heavy deadlift workout
see how mad you are after that you're
it's just you don't have the energy your
body doesn't have the ability to like
physiologically respond with anger at a
certain point of exhaustion you know
what I mean like work out till you pass
out
your body can't like even trigger the
emotion you know what I mean I do agree
or not yeah totally yeah like like you
because when you think about it it's
like your heart rate has to rise and you
have to like and anger is like a
motivation to do something yeah it
reminds me of like in Fight Club like
once they started fighting like
everything else the volume got turned
down correct yeah I I think the quote
was like the ability to to let that
which does not matter truly slide and
they're like on the bus and like
somebody bumps into them and they're
like I don't care right yeah just and
that's another reason you see guys where
you like it's never the guy who's like
hyper Vigilant trying to fight you in
the bar who's the guy you have to worry
about it's the guy who's like yeah
that's cool but like if you keep going
you know I'm gonna murder you
this this got me this sent me as the
kids say bro you wouldn't believe that
but we only have two more legs days till
Christmas it's October guys that's crazy
yeah we're talking a one leg day every
six weeks but you know
I guess that's the kind of math we're
dealing with here at the Bro Science
Academy when the gym is empty and you
can finally get a real work at it okay
let's see what is real oh my God he's
doing the booty pumps he's doing the
side shuffle he's doing the hit machine
he's doing the bad girls all that stuff
love it and that's what guys do you know
when the cat's away the mice will play
how long we going oh my goodness
gracious should I do a little recap of
um
the liver King next week yes you know
what let's tune in next week and I'm
just going to give my in-depth thoughts
on it I'm going to give an updated
version of my Natty or not you know
somebody pointed out to me because
remember this guy actually I'll get his
name and I might even have him on or
just feed I want to give him some credit
before because he was like
he hit me up and after I talked about
the liver King basically being like
you're an idiot if you don't think the
liver King is on steroids I've changed
my mind to some degree and I'm ready to
make essentially The Devil's Advocate
case for the liver King
being natural oh I know it's great but
you know I have to be honest here I have
to
admit when I go I can see a different
perspective I don't know either way but
after meeting him and seeing in person
although it's not even the visual
because see him in person I'm like
you're actually more jacked than I
thought you were but I learned some
things about him that I thought were
interesting and will allow me to make
the opposing case and a guy I remember
had messaged me he's like I work with
the liver King like
I I sell him something I forget what it
was exactly but he's like I've been to
his house like I've had dinner with him
I remember that you mentioned that on
the show right yeah yeah and so he hit
him up he's like oh yeah I remember when
I was like [ __ ] you block
um no but I want to give that guy credit
because like he's he's he wasn't doing
an a dickish way but like you have to go
like yeah man I've changed my mind and
now do I think we we were coming to that
conclusion
in exactly the same way no but he was
sort of using an appeal to his character
he was like this guy and at the time
that didn't mean [ __ ] to me oh yeah he's
a good guy I can't do steroids like
right but a similar uh perspective that
you have with grego Gallagher right
where you're like this guy he's just
correct yeah there is an element of like
I look at grego Gallagher I'm like he
isn't the type of guy who would use
steroids I just know that for a fact
having met many people who do and who
don't and it's it has nothing to do with
his statements on like you could tell me
you're an addict I don't give a [ __ ]
that's just one tiny little bit of
information that I'll use to make my own
determination but it's everything else
it's how you think about other
substances it's how you you know just
sort of approach the world in general
and the level of sort of like Risk you
take or the the you know your
neuroticism with things you put in your
body it's a whole you know complex mix
of things and I've shifted in my
perspective of the liver king after
after meeting and also knows like look
of course there's a personal bias when
you meet somebody but
um I think you guys also know that I
just like I don't care as much but I
think that also puts me in a position to
like
judge more clearly in a way because I
see a lot of guys who've made their
names off Natty or not it's like there's
a level of like
vindictiveness that goes into it where
you it's like you must be on steroids
and it's not every guy's like that but
I've noticed some people like especially
who don't have as nice of physiques as
the guys that they're looking at it's
like no like it's it's a desire to
dismiss somebody which of course comes
from a fragile ego with regards to uh
you know your sort of feeling threatened
by somebody else's achievement or nice
physique and you're just you're you're
primed you're primed to look at
something
and find a certain conclusion and I'm
not saying the case for the liver King
being on steroids isn't good I'm just I
I basically was saying before there's no
opposite case and I'm ready to deliver
that opposite case next week so tune in
dude I left y'all on a cliffhanger dude
Harley out